so during your two weeks notice I assume
were you planning out like what your day
was going to be like what's the six
months yeah yeah it was I had a I
definitely had a plan and I knew I knew
that I wanted to spend the time writing
and I just needed to figure out what I
was most efficient at I think and for me
at that time it was structure like I was
always a really good character writer
and so I knew I needed to learn
structure better and so that was one of
the things I knew I was gonna have to
work on and so I bought the books and I
did all that kind of stuff and so I was
I was definitely prepared during that
time so that when I could just I could
jump off and begin my six-month
education since you know six months
actually ticks by pretty quickly
yeah and I'm wondering what was day one
like oh my god if I could even think
about what that was like I think um I
think there was a huge sense of relief
in it in that I was finally doing what I
probably should have been doing for the
last couple of years so you know and I
felt like I was gonna enjoy every moment
of this it may I may only get you know
six months of doing it so that's that's
basically what I did is I just really
enjoyed that this is gonna be the life
of a writer you know and probably that
was sort of bittersweet too because you
thought maybe this was the only six
months that she would ever this would
happen exactly but I but I wasn't
thinking that far ahead because I had a
lot of confidence that if I did this I
could make it happen
so I don't think I ever got caught up in
that oh this might be the only time I
get to do this I think I was looking at
it more like this is the beginning and I
just have to figure out how to make this
last and how to make the money back so
that I could continue to do it how did
you know you could trust yourself
because I think that's probably the
number one thing is knowing you could
trust your time and allocating the right
resources I think I've always been
someone who trusts myself in that um
yeah
I guess when it comes to that kind of a
thing you know the only person that's
gonna make something happen as you and I
feel like just in general my perspective
is you have a lot of control over that
so I think for me
you know I gotten into USC it was a very
competitive program graduated at the top
of my class I had won awards while I was
there I knew I was a good writer I
wasn't sure why I wasn't working like I
wasn't sure why I wasn't selling scripts
and so for me a lot of it was like well
it's not because you're not a good
writer it must be because you're
distracted you're not focused so you
just got to get that back and once you
do you'll be able to move forward and I
think that's where my head was at the
time yeah I think so many people it's
that big dilemma of like do I want to be
comfortable and have a job and have one
that has a good title and that friends
and family are gonna respect and I
respect myself for having or do I want
to unfortunately have life be a little
bit uncomfortable and that's so were you
prepared to be uncomfortable whether
it's cutting back on spending oh yeah
and I mean I think I still into this day
I think that I think I would tell any
writer that that you have to be willing
to sell your nice car to sell your house
and move back into an apartment you have
to love this job more than you love
anything you own because it can go away
like that and just because you you have
some success doesn't mean you should
ever get comfortable with it because
things change the industry is always
changing you're changing you're getting
older you know there's new people coming
in there's so much influx all the time
that you really have to be in a place
where you're willing to give that up you
have to love it enough and if you don't
love it enough and you really just want
money there are a lot easier ways to go
make money than to be a screenwriter so
that would be my advice during the six
months were you doing this seven days a
week yeah Wow yeah but it didn't feel
like it didn't feel like work because I
felt like I was finally getting to do
what I really wanted to do and I woke up
every morning loving to write couldn't
wait to get back on the script and keep
working on it
so it never felt like work to me so
lastly if someone said Christine I know
this is a huge risk and I know that I
shouldn't take a line of credit out
I shouldn't or even something use up my
savings whatever it is but I want to
risk it and I'm willing to face the
consequences what would you say are some
hard fast do's and don'ts that's a great
question I would say go into it with a
plan you can't waste a single minute of
that time so go into it with a plan and
tell other people your plan if this is
what you want to do first of all if you
tell many people that you're gonna spend
your life savings to make a film or to
pretend to be a screenwriter for six
months most people are gonna tell you
not to do it
most people told me not to do they
thought it was crazy but I think you
have to ask yourself those really hard
questions like how much do you trust
yourself how much do you want this and
how much are you willing to lose and
give up you can always go back and get a
job at a Y or State Farm or wherever
you're working and and in general
successful people tend to be successful
no matter what they do right so you know
if you were being promoted if that job
you can get another job you'll probably
be promoted at that job as well so I
would say but go into it with a plan and
know what you want to get out of it and
have a way to measure that success
because a lot of times I think writers
we aren't very good at measuring what's
working for us and what isn't we just
sort of kind of willy-nilly go today I
feel like writing this and now the
scripts done and maybe I'll turn it in
and maybe I won't and maybe men rewrite
it and you have to really kind of look
at your life like a business and I think
if you can manage it that way you have a
better you're better prepared for seeing
what's working and then and continuing
on that route or seeing what's not
working and abandoning that strategy so
you have to look at it more like a
business that's that's a big thing too
you